hey guys and welcome to another Advanced
flipping guide this is going to be
number six uh today I'm going to be
going over uh how to flip extremely rare
items now I'm not talking about
godswords or imbued hearts or items that
are rare but people are using I'm
talking about extremely rare items like
the mummy outfit or anku socks clue
scroll items that people only use for um
cosmetic reasons um other items that
just really aren't used that much of
course they have to be traded a little
bit or else we won't be able to flip
them but the main benefit to this method
is because almost nobody buys these
items the emergence on them can be
extremely good probably the highest in
the game this is going to require a fair
bit of money and a fair bit of patience
uh so be prepared to leave uh your items
in there quite a while all right let's
get started so to start off you're going
to need a tool to look at the Grand
exchange uh cuz this will make it quite
a bit easier I personally am using GE
tracker which is a sponsor of mine um
for this video uh if you just sign up
for a free account uh you will be able
to do pretty much everything I'm doing
in the video uh so go check them out
there will be a link in the description
for that okay so next up we need to find
uh what items we're going to be looking
at uh now G tracker does have a highest
margin page but this is catering more to
in market items um I'm going to be using
it to look at the item to do some
research but I'll show you in a minute
why actually just manually inputting
your items into GE tracker is a lot more
useful uh so let's go first of all to
find an item and the place I mainly look
is on the wiki uh so I'm looking at the
master clue scroll rewards and I would
recommend looking at master elite and
maybe hard uh clue rewards because they
will have some pretty obscure items that
of course are still traded because they
are coming into the game uh but not not
many people are wanting them there are
other sources for these items but this
is the biggest kind of collection of
them Al together uh so let's start off
by looking at okay let's try the mummy
outfit so there's five different pieces
here mummy's feet uh so we're just going
to look up mummy and G tracker okay so
as we can see there are almost none
traded so this might be a little too
obscure but we'll have to see I flipped
this item before and it has worked in
the past so let's try the mummy's feet
so now the first thing I'm going to look
at here is first how many are traded a
day uh so we scroll down here pass the
price to the Daily traded we can see
it's
about let's say five on average uh which
is not a lot um maybe a little bit more
if we come over here to the day graph um
which is only available to premium
members uh we can see that there's not
that many traded but because of how slow
this item is if we just go to the week
graph uh we can actually see pretty much
every single transaction um pretty
accurately so this is where a tool like
this can be extremely useful because
there's not a lot of transactions
because of this uh they're all going to
be logged on here very uh visibly and
easy to view uh so we can see that the
margin is over the course of a week
going from about 470 to uh 630 not going
to be worth our time uh because this is
going to take a long time to trade this
can only take see that's yesterday yeah
there's only there's not a lot traded
here I'm going to skip on this item I
think for now all right next up I'm look
at the zamra godsword ornament kit and
now one thing worth mentioning is I
would try to for this particular method
I would stick to items
under 100 traded a day and again to do
that you're just going to want to come
down here keep it on the month and I'll
show you every day so every day there's
about uh 20 to 30 of these traded this
is an ideal uh amount because there's
still going to be enough coming into the
game to actually buy them but the margin
can be extremely good so we can see here
we can look at what over the last 24
hours uh the lowest point has been is
about 826 and the highest is about
929 uh not too bad but I feel like we
can do better if we look at the weak
graph same deal it's pretty easy to just
still look at the dots and it'll give
you pretty accurate estimate on what the
prices are looking at now let's have a
look at another item the
anq set we'll type in anq okay so this
one seems to be traded a little bit more
now let's try the anq socks now one
thing that makes it a lot more powerful
to just look up items manually as we can
see here G trctor is only showing 141k
as a margin uh so that's not going to
pop up in the um automatic feed for
everybody uh so we have a look here go
down to uh the week and then go down to
the
day now the reason it's not showing a
big margin is because of this the price
has changed in the last six or something
hours uh but that's not really a true
reflection of what the margin could be
we can see back here um it was regularly
selling for about 4.9 mil and we could
try to buy it for uh 4 I know 4.6 mil or
something like that um so I think we
might try one of these enough are traded
every day as well to make this
worthwhile so maybe we'll try buying one
for
46 uh 57 and we'll try selling it for
4900 all right so we're putting this in
for 46 57k and I'm only going to do one
of these my goal is to fill up my offer
slot with singular items this will help
speed up the process you have a much
higher chance of buying eight different
items than eight of one item of course
and yeah so we'll go ahead and start
looking for some other items and check
back in once I've filled my uh offer
slots okay so the plan was to fill out
the inventory but uh just 5 minutes into
doing this actually two of my items came
through both the anku socks and anku
mask uh came through at the same time uh
so I'll probably just go ahead and put
another offering for the socks so let's
go ahead and pop these items into sell
quickly then I'll have a look at the
other items I did uh so let's get this
open here so anq socks we bought for
about 4657 and we're looking to sell for
about
4,900 uh so we'll sell that for
4897 uh looks good and I'll put another
offer into to buy another one of these
for 4657 so it'll be pretty much all of
our money now let's move on to the anku
mask which we bought for 9.8 mil okay so
this item looks very promising uh looks
like I could sell it hopefully for about
10.4 mil uh so we'll pop that in there
for 10.4 mil 10 let's 2 3
49k uh so that's
10.35 mil that's about
540k we're going to make off the item so
I think instead of doing um the third
age mask I might just buy another one of
the Anu masks um this one did have well
let's have a look at it on G tracker
quickly third age Mage hat does look
pretty good uh we're trying to buy it
for 13405 and maybe sell it for
13842 uh so that would sell pretty
quickly it's now be
400k and uh actually you know what I'm
just going to leave it the way it is
diversify the items more and yeah we'll
have a look at the other couple items I
put in as well um I went with the
mummy's legs just because it did have a
pretty interesting um margin on it from
915 to 1250 that's pretty good I'm not
sure if I'll get this and um Aus
spectacles looked actually really cool
so it's a pretty cheap item only 1 mil
but looks like I could routinely sell it
for about 1.4 mil uh so I actually put
an offering for three of them just
because they're only 1 mil each and the
margin on it was extremely good uh it
seems just recently dropped down to a
very low price and um we did also an
ornament kit uh not as rare but still
only about 50 or 60 traded a Daye So the
plan here is to leave this in now don't
be mistaken I'm leaving this in for a
while like a day probably 24 hours at
least I'll be checking back in regularly
to see if I buy any of the items but be
prepared to wait quite a while and I'll
come back with hopefully some sales okay
guys we are back and it's about uh 2 and
1 half days later uh so just to give you
some info uh most of my offers came
through on I guess what was it Wednesday
night or sorry Tuesday night and uh when
I left on Wednesday for a one day kind
of getaway um all these items had come
through I ended up buying two Sous
spectacles a pair of mummy legs um two
pairs of anq socks and two pairs of anq
masks as well as the dragon citar
ornament kit and uh when I left I just
popped them all into cell so I came back
and this is what has sold uh not
everything so I'm going to have to
readjust some things but this is kind of
how it's going to go uh the margin
changes enough even uh a long time will
not make the item sell automatically so
let's go have a quick look at the items
we'll pull up the ones I haven't sold
yet and we'll just leave those and sell
them on my own time uh let's pull up the
m mask and pull out the anq socks all
right so the start off we'll start on
the left anq socks uh we sold for 48 94k
and we bought them for
4657 getting us a 237k profit which is
not too bad uh the anq mask did really
well we sold for
10349 uh mil or pretty much 10.3 mil and
we bought only for 9810 nettin 539k on
that flip which is really awesome uh the
seia spectacles went really well we
ended up selling them for 1350 each uh
which gives us about 678k in total over
340 on uh each item and then we have the
dragon cimar ornament kit which we sold
for 2684 and we bought for 2522 n is
162k so in total off of these well four
flips which required very little effort
just time we made 1.6 mil or
166k which I'm pretty happy with really
easy for items you just leave in for a
while and they do eventually come
through really easy to track them on uh
ge tracking tools such as G tracker or o
buddy and yeah really easy money to be
made uh we'll go ahead and sell these
off later but if we get similar margins
we can make 2 to 2.5 mil in total off of
all these items anyway guys I hope you
enjoyed the video again this is going to
be for mostly people who are okay being
patient and have enough money to invest
in these expensive items so hope you
guys enjoyed and I'll see you guys in
the next video
[Music]